in the United States there's legal
corruption and then there's illegal
corruption there's the law for the rich
and there's the law for everybody else
and we've now learned that Donald
Trump's constant and endless trips to
his own golf courses aren't just
funneling taxpayer money into Trump's
pockets of course in Secret Service and
the entire mobile White House pays
Trump's golf courses and needs to set up
shop there when Trump goes we've now
learned that lobbyists and corporate
CEOs are paying millions of dollars to
Donald Trump's golf courses to be there
at the same time as Donald Trump and
presumably suspiciously get access to
the president USA Today did a really
good investigation into this and they
found dozens and dozens of key lobbyists
and CEOs who have memberships at Donald
Trump's golf clubs and many have visited
on the exact same days that Donald Trump
was there what USA Today is pretty
brilliant I'll put up on the screen sort
of an explanation of what they did
members of the clubs Trump has visited
most often as president in Florida New
Jersey and Virginia include at least 50
executives who've companies hold federal
contracts and 21 lobbyists and trade
group officials two-thirds played on one
of the 58 days the president was there
according to the scores they posted
online because membership lists at
Trump's clubs are secret the public has
until now been unable to assess the
conflicts they could create USA Today
found the names of 4,500 members by
reviewing social media and a public
website golfers used to track their
handicaps then researched and contacted
hundreds to determine whether they had
business with the government pretty
brilliant right golfers whose names are
secret as members of golf of trumps golf
clubs still post their golf scores
online and that was the information that
USA Today was able to use to figure out
who is going to these clubs and we now
know that they are overlapping with
Trump here very very often this includes
defense contractor executives South
Korean government lobbyists the leader
of a pesticide trade group that has been
lobbying the Trump administration not to
ban an insecticide that his client
produces that scientists say poses a
risk to human health and I want to be
super clear this is all legal okay
the hundred thousand dollar initiation
fees the annual dues the entire thing
it's legal because it's sort of
uncharted territory in terms of what
we're seeing now ethically and morally
this is incredibly disturbing but it
appears as though this is legal and the
obvious question is well when they
golfed on the same days trump was there
did they have access to Donald Trump and
of course officially the answer is no
but we know Trump just hangs out at the
golf clubs he talks to everybody there's
security breaches all the time
discussing issues of foreign
geopolitical foreign policy and
geopolitical importance in a public
courtyard with guests hanging around so
it would be very difficult to believe
that these lobbyists and CEOs aren't
talking directly to Trump I think this
is our uncharted territory but it's not
because it's we haven't had rich
presidents before I don't have I mean
look at the bushes for example they made
a lot of money with oil but it's not
like you visit an oil refinery and
hobnob with the socialites they're right
wealthy people now have a much more
direct way than ever to have these
confidential meetings with the President
and they're of getting these meetings
specifically and by meetings I don't
mean a scheduled formal meeting I mean
encounters they are getting these as a
result of payments they make which will
personally enrich the president so at
first we thought Trump's going to these
golf courses all the time and he's super
lazy he doesn't want to be president and
it's funneling some money in to his
businesses through the Secret Service
and the mobile White House we've now
learned it's actually a place where
millions of dollars from lobbyists and
corporate CEOs who want Trump to do this
that or the other thing are showing up
and funneling millions of dollars into
Trump's businesses this is the opposite
of being the drain the swamp guy but
again it's all legal the system we have
allows for this or at least it doesn't
prevent this at this point in you know
previous affluent presidents would make
it a point to divest from their
companies or just distance themself as
much as they can but if all you can see
is some ethical backlash and there's no
financial reason or legal reason for him
to remove himself from his companies
like we're going to do it or not at this
point and didn't Jimmy Carter like
divest from like a peanut farm in in
Georgia or something like some
that how could it possibly even it's
laughable he did the right thing but
it's laughable given what we're seeing
with Donald Trump at this point send me
your thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
the show is on Twitter at David Pakman
show today's sponsor is movement watches
I'm wearing my movement watch today love
it get compliments on it everywhere I go
movement watches was started by two
broke college kids they wanted to wear
stylish watches couldn't afford them
they'd go to department stores they'd
see watches they liked they look at the
price tag and the price tag would have a
4 in front of it and I'm not talking
about $40 or a 5 in front of it and I'm
not talking about 50 something dollars
so by selling directly to the consumers
online they've cut out the retail markup
they've cut out the middleman and they
are starting with really really great
prices of just $95 a fraction of what
you would expect to pay for a similarly
stylish watch a similarly well-designed
watch at a department store and the
pricing goes along with the classic
design the quality construction the
minimalism that is part of the style and
they have now sold over a million
watches in over 160 countries I love my
movement watch I encourage you to check
out movement watches save 15% with free
shipping and free returns at MVM
t-dot-com forward slash Pakman that's PA
que ma n okay save 15% free shipping
free returns
MVM t.com /pa que ma n